Hey guys, welcome to General Energy Podcast #70. Ray Peat, Georgie Dinkov. Ray, I just
interrupted you, but we were talking before about like, what was your take on Australia?
And I thought you had an interesting take that I really haven't heard before, so I thought
everybody would enjoy that.
For several decades, it has seemed that they've been heavily manipulated by the CIA or whoever
the world manipulators are. And so I see their extreme reactions as being a test case for
how fast they can get away with imposing stuff on different parts of the world. But I think
the reaction there is strong enough that maybe they're going to hold back and think of something
a little less crude for the US and Europe.
And then we also talked about, I told you I was a little confused on why the power elites
would want to turn the US into a third world country. And we were talking about just the
possibility that the citizenry of the US are the last remaining threat to the power elite.
And once they were subdued, they could do all their illicit, weird activities without
any interruption.
Yeah. In one of her recent videos, Lee Merritt, an anti-vax physician, she said that in her
state the number of people who own guns would be the equivalent of, I forget what it was,
the fifth largest army in the world.
Why do you think they don't simply own guns? They also regularly shoot them. So they're
there. Well, maybe they're not on par with an active military, but they can put up a
probably a pretty decent resistance if things really start getting ugly.
Yeah. Even though the firepower is like a million to one in favor of the Pentagon, the
actual ground level situation, if you have a thousand people with little guns and a hundred
soldiers with bazookas and tanks becomes a better balance.
Do you think the Pentagon has managed to vet its, what you call it, the most loyal soldiers
it has to the point where they're completely confident that none of these people will turn
on them if they're being ordered to attack their own, like their own families?
I think that's the purpose of Biden's talking about dishonorable discharge for people who
don't get vaccinated. He doesn't want any ambiguous people ambivalent about following
orders once he gets the vaccine resistors out, then he's got a nice robot army.
So we can expect something really bad when all those people are vaccinated, all the soldiers.
Yeah. If they're really giving them the same vaccine that is causing the CDC's death and
disability numbers to rise astronomically, then it's going to weaken the army. But I
would suppose that they know better than to give the regular vaccines to anyone they want
to rely on.
Did you see that the CDC chief, whatever her name is, she overruled her own advisory committee
and basically went against the recommendations. The advisory committee said, no, most people
don't need a booster as corrupt as we are. That's too much even for us. And she said,
nope, I'm going to overrule you. Is that legal under federal law? Does the agency have like
supreme power over the agency?
The agency's concept are internal regulations. I've interacted with some agencies that just
really didn't take their own regulations seriously.
So what I'm hearing is that these advisory committees are largely ceremonial. Basically,
they're just sitting there making mood decisions, but ultimately it's the agency head.
Yeah. Just for giving it a little prestige.
I'm scrolling through looking for an article, but it was talking about during H1N1, the
government class was issued different vaccines than the population. And so what you're saying
is like rooted in the mainstream article that I had come across at some point.
Several people have been talking about the evidence that several different vaccines or
non-vaccines have been issued and the elite get the non-vaccines.
Just a week after it emerged that German armed forces were getting a different kind of H1N1
vaccine to the general population, Der Spiegel magazine reports that the government will
also get special treatment.
What you sent me Dolores Cahill's video, and she was talking about an interesting way of
kind of holding people accountable that were forcing vaccines on people. Can you talk a
little bit more about that?
A personal liability lawsuit is one of them. You have injured me and I'll take you to court
and get redress. Another one was making them aware of the fact that they're committing
a crime. If they do anything to coerce someone in any way, but especially to take an experimental
medical treatment, that is worse than simple undefined coercion. But coercion is a felony
in some states and a serious misdemeanor in all the rest. Federal law allows up to three
years in prison for coercion.
But these lawsuits, they would only apply to actual to the actual doctors, the private
industry, because the government officials have qualified immunity, right? Just like
the cops. They cannot be sued for doing bad things to us.
Yeah, but your employer who is administering the illegal regulation, they would undoubtedly
say it was just following the orders. But that has not been working very well.
So even though OSHA can mandate the employer and say, look, we're going to fine you if
you don't vaccinate your employees and the employer does, that the employer is kind of
caught between a rock and a hard place because both places can attack, right?
Yeah. And if the employees make it expensive by suing their employers for damages, if they
get fired, then the company has to start thinking which side they'll take.
Many of the small ones will probably just simply simply fold and close shop, which I'm
starting to think that may be that may be one of the desired side effects, even if it's
not planned.
Well, the plan as expressed by Eric Schmidt two years, more than two years ago, it was
in line with the Rockefeller Foundation and other long range plans. But the Pentagon Committee
that Eric Schmidt was the chairman of outlined the need to destroy the existing economy of
the United States so that it could be quickly replaced by a digital artificial intelligence
economy that was expressed in 2019 before there was a pandemic.
You can see this basically, we all shop from Amazon, we all get our I.T. from Google and
we all get our health care from a single whatever mandatory provider that we don't even get
our health care. We we are administered health care against our wishes.
Yeah. And as the small businesses went broke, the Amazon and other giant corporations just
about doubled their wealth.
Yeah. The office building that I'm that where my office is basically the company that was
renting it out to small companies like me. They went bankrupt and BlackRock, the large
the massive financial company, moved in and bought all the real estate in D.C.
Yeah. Right. Do you have opinions on Vanguard and BlackRock and how they own a lot of the
huge major corporations? Like people think there can't be coordination between these
huge like so-called private corporations and stuff, but apparently they own like everything.
Yeah. I saw someone analyzing the tentacles of Vanguard. They're everywhere with five
or six percent ownership where they can have a strong influence.
You know who I think did?
They're just about identical with the World Economic Forum in their policies and reach.
The guest who owns the private funds behind Vanguard, it's basically a who's who of the
new cons, the Bush family, the Rumsfeld family, the Clintons, the Rockefellers, the Rothschilds.
Yeah. So no surprises here. I guess how this thing is unfolding. Is there anything you
think is incredibly weak or a route to escape? Or do you think it's they're more or less
the plan is going according to how they planned it?
I think it's going according to the plan.
You don't see any glitches in their push for the vaccine for everybody and for the lockdowns.
I mean, I can tell you as liberal and woke as DC is, if another lockdown is attempted
here, even the liberals will revolt and probably hang the mayor if she tries something like
that.
It would be good to see.
Right. I'm saying that even those people who were convinced initially that this is a good
thing and they're trying to save the world and everybody should be vaccinated. They've
had enough of basically being stuck at home with the screaming children and doing the
work of both teachers and doctors and everything and doing their own work. So even the I don't
know, the cool cities, I think the population has had enough. So I just don't see another
lockdown unless there's a false flag operation with another virus or something militarily
happens domestically.
They keep talking about alternative panic producers like a sudden breakdown of food
supply or banking crashes, Internet shutdowns and so on. They've been talking about that
for so long. I think it means they have something in mind, not necessarily those.
In one of the in one of your articles, you talked about how the Appalachian region has
the lowest death rate from breast cancer, even though the rates of breast cancer are
higher than the rest of the country. And you also mentioned how extremely rural areas and
poor areas would probably not notice, you know, whenever the collapse of the world economy
arrives. So a question to me is like, is there any reason why you wouldn't consider going
to the Appalachian region? You don't think it's high enough altitude or you think the
culture there is not very, I don't know, friendly? Just curious.
Yeah, there are pockets of culture that could be acceptable, but other places, the xenophobia
basically not just according to skin color, but just having the wrong accent of an outsider
can be difficult. I would choose a completely different country where they're used to tourists
and Anglo people don't have such xenophobia.
Ron Unz has an article on his website recently about a journalist who went to Welch. It's
a town in southern West Virginia. It's the poorest town in the poorest county in the
entire country. And he basically chronicled the decline of the area, which used to be
booming in the 50s due to coal and kind of coincided with the peak of America, from what
I'm understanding. You said that the 50s was really the time where people had everything
they needed and nothing they didn't. And just the way he described the area is that because
it's so poor, they have really opened up to tourists and they're really friendly. And
there's basically very little Internet and very little cell phone service and everything
is dirt cheap there. So I don't know, sounds very attractive to me. If I have to make a
move from out of D.C., that will probably be the first place I would try.
Yeah, I think poverty in terms of the Internet culture is a very creative, highly progressive
thing.
Well, it seems like people from Monterrey are like very westernized and that's something
that...
Oh, Monterrey, Mexico?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah. Buildings there, I've seen slogans, "Hitler was right." The cops there are the nastiest
I've ever seen in Mexico. It's not just Americanized, but it's the worst industrialization can do
to a government.
Good to know. One thing I was interested in getting your take on, I'm not sure if we've
ever talked about it, but the incoherent narratives that conflict, like just watching Fauci contradict
himself like a hundred times. And I think a lot of people would tend to say, "Oh, that's
because our leaders are so incompetent." But what do you think about that being like a
strategy of terror, of confusion, like to make people so confused that it inactivates
them because they don't know what to do because nothing makes sense?
Yeah, I think it's natural for them to just talk through their hat. And it turns out that
that also is producing confusion and working in the direction they want people to go, panic
and confusion.
I have a book, it's by a guy named Kurt Lewin. I think it's like 1942 or something. And he
was some big wig at the Tavistock Institute. And in his book, he says, "If we just confuse
people enough, they won't know what to do." And even if you're like a renegade, you will
be inactive because there'll be no clear path forward of what to do because everything is
so...
I mean, that's basically what they do in the US. The people that consider themselves radicals
are aligned with Citibank and Wells Fargo with the exact things they believe.
Yeah, four years or 2016 election, I guess, I noticed that the Communist Party of the
US was supporting Hillary Clinton. That's a perfect example of confusing people to be
utterly useless.
Or it shows how little commonness there is in the Communist Party of the United States.
Okay, well, we can take the show in really any direction we want. Ray, did you want to...
you are working on something. Did you want to talk about that? Or we could go into questions.
Really we have free for all here.
Questions are okay. I'm right in the middle of thinking about what to write about something
to do with development and immunity and how the whole system has been warped so much that
it's almost impossible to talk about how the immune system works. And so it's a perfect
background for people saying ridiculous things about vaccines, for example, because there's
no solid ground for making a decisive and final argument about any issue in the immune
system. You have to see the history going back more than 100 years to see why the situation
is so muddled around the vaccine issue.
Did Jamie Cunliffe and Polly Metzinger, did anybody take them seriously? Was that more
of a static view of immunity ever a real contender against the traditional view?
Jamie Cunliffe and his danger hypothesis, I think he got right to the center of the
issue, but he hasn't been keeping up with his studies in the last 15 or 20 years. He's
hardly refined his thinking. What he did was very good. And the Polly Metzinger ideas have
been to some extent adopted by the mainstream, but in the process, their meaning has been
lost. The potential of Polly Metzinger's system or perspective was to go the Cunliffe
direction. It has instead gone the whole clonal selection right down the mainstream, everything
staying the same.
And if I could butcher that point of view, it's that tissue injury, it comes before any
kind of bacteria or fungi or anything like that. Right. And so if you're worried about
immunity, you should be worrying about limiting tissue injury.
Yeah. And our body is concerned with coming into existence and maintaining that existence
and improving it if possible. And the Cunliffe idea is that when something goes wrong, whether
it's a mechanical or radiation or chemical damage or an organism that somehow created
damage in our system, that it's a damage that our body is concerned with. And in the process
of fixing that damage, it takes out the pathogen, whether it's part of an organism or a toxin
or even radiation damage, the body takes the measures necessary to maintain its integrity
and not really thinking or designed for or evolved to attack enemies or other than self.
It's the process of optimizing the self that has a sideline. It happens that sometimes
we develop the antibodies and so on for taking out viruses and bacteria and parasites.
Well, there's some studies showing that depending on the occupation, specific occupations had
a much higher rate of autoimmune conditions like rheumatoid arthritis, like boxers, since
they continuously damage their knuckles and various other joints, they're much more likely
to develop this autoimmune condition. Hasn't this ever attracted attention of the mainstream
medicine saying, well, there is a connection between chronic tissue injury and autoimmune
conditions?
Very little. Twenty-five or thirty years ago, I saw a single article in which they took
a piece of cow cartilage and I forget who's injected it into maybe rabbits. And when it
was in a fresh condition, it didn't elicit antibodies. But if they just twisted the cartilage,
gave it a little bit of mechanical stress, then it elicited antibodies. And that was
like an image of how easy it is to induce the antibody reactions you see in autoimmune
conditions.
Have you seen the recent studies? I know you've said this many times, but recently they confirmed
that endotoxin is directly responsible for the flares of rheumatoid arthritis.
Yeah, I've been following that general line that any injuries to the tissue will bring
up the so-called autoimmune system. Virus infections in some of the experiments were
lethal if the organism wasn't allowed to produce antibodies. The virus that would bring up
the antibodies would in itself not produce the disease, but the antibody itself was there
mostly to clear out the damaged tissue rather than to attack the virus.
Do you think chronic low-grade endotoxemia as they call it can be a factor in many of
these autoimmune conditions constantly causing this small level of injury? And then eventually,
I guess if the organism is energetically depleted severely, then sort of like a chronic autoimmune
condition sets in?
Yeah, and things like lupus and the famous named autoimmune diseases including Sjogren's
syndrome and thyroid.
Hashimoto.
Hashimoto, yeah.
And probably MS. In some of these such as lupus, I've seen very clear diagnoses of everything
confirming that it was the so-called lupus condition causing the arthritis and other
symptoms. But just by correcting their vitamin D, calcium intake, progesterone and thyroid,
all of the symptoms disappeared and they gradually started having a regression of the antibodies.
Right, so you're saying you don't need to go on the carnivore diet if you have an autoimmune
disease?
No, keeping your blood glucose up and your carbon dioxide high from oxidizing glucose,
I think those are the basic anti-inflammatory things that will correct all of the autoimmune
diseases.
I was making a joke, but actually, when a person does eat an all-meat diet and they
do experience like an improvement in their symptoms, probably would be a reduction in
endotoxin, right?
Yeah. So many people are eating indigestible stuff that causes inflammation of their intestine
and a meat diet will simply represent the absence of toxic indigestible foods, but that
gives you very quick relief like a fast. A week of fast has very often completely relieved
the spondylitis types of arthritis and inflammation. But after you are on that diet for a while,
the excitatory inflammatory effect of the unbalanced phosphate and iron intake, a very
unbalanced diet eventually brings up other problems just as serious.
One last question about this and then we can move on. In the complex biochemical web of
all the stress substances, we were talking last time about PTH being like all roads lead
to parathyroid hormone. Where would you put endotoxin in that whole mix?
It's a constant threat everywhere and all the time. The bad diet choices will make it
take over and become dominant. But even with the best diet, just something like a physical
shock or an emotional shock can reduce the barrier function of the intestine enough and
slow the digestion so that you absorb more endotoxin. So it's very controllable, but
it's always a present danger.
I saw some old studies in the 50s and 60s showing that the main mechanism, they suggested
that the main mechanism of the increased barrier permeability in the gut during stress was
estrogen because when they basically gave an estrogen blocker, the effects of stress
on the increased endotoxin in the blood disappeared. Do you share that view?
Oh yeah, the capillaries are where the intestine barrier is most important. And everywhere
in the body, estrogen weakens the capillary barrier.
Amazing stuff. Thanks for that. Or maybe should we do a little advertisement using air quotes
here for your newsletter? Okay, the newsletter is available by email now and it's $28 US
which can be paid through PayPal at raypeetsnewsletter@gmail.com. You can also order all of Ray's books
from PMS to menopause, progesterone and orthomolecular medicine, gender of energy, my favorite, mind
and tissue, nutrition for women, and then Progest-E from Keenogen. So you can email
Catherine to purchase Progest-E, keenogen@gmail.com. And each bottle contains 3,400 milligrams
of progesterone. And while we're on the topic of progesterone, I'm going to kick questions
off here with Marcelo's question. And he says, "Hey Danny, can you ask Ray if he had ever
seen or heard of a woman regaining her fertility taking high dose progesterone? We're talking
someone who has been infertile for a decade or more."
When I was teaching nutrition classes, there were several women who said they had been
infertile for more than 10 years. And it was a three month class. And usually there were
two or three people during that class who would suddenly get pregnant, just with almost
all of them, just with diet changes. But it was to increase their progesterone and thyroid
and to get their estrogen under control. And one woman, a medical doctor, she had diagnosed
ovarian failure when she was, I think, about 35. And by carefully taking a blood test about
every week or two, she imitated the natural hormones of the cycle with small amounts,
generally of both thyroid and progesterone. That doesn't take a huge amount when it's
at the right time. And I think, I forget her exact age, but she was in her 40s and had
been perfectly infertile for over 10 years and had a baby very quickly as soon as she
got her blood test showing the hormones in the right range.
That's amazing. Thanks for that. Okay. Okay. First question, raise thoughts on the importance
of posture and health. Does good posture come from good health or vice versa?
I think good health makes you feel springy and energetic. And so you take on the aspect
of a springy, energetic person. If everything hurts and you're tired, naturally everything
is going to slump.
I think a long time ago you wrote to somebody I knew and you were specifically talking about
maybe DHEA and testosterone causing a lot of the slumping. I mean, of course, those
are energetic types of therapies.
Yeah. And the pregnenolone and progesterone work with them. The fascia that hold up your
skin are, even though they're basically fibroblast type cells, in the absence of those protective
steroids, they go limp. And given just pregnenolone, for example, but the others all have a similar
effect, just a dose of pregnenolone will cause the fascia to contract showing that they have
the properties of smooth muscle cells besides being the tough connective tissue that holds
your whole body organs in place. And for example, if the fascia get loose, the tendons and capsules
around tissues all get slack and it can lead to the prolapse of the uterus, for example.
And several months ago, a woman told me that her doctor had planned to do surgery to pin
her uterus back where it should be, but she was using a mixture of DHEA and progesterone,
both topically and orally, and her uterus normalized. No surgery needed to hold it in
place. That same thing happens throughout your body. Undoubtedly, it's going to affect
your posture and the feeling of strength in your joints.
Amazing. Thanks for that. Okay. Does Ray think it's possible that apes are actually devolved
human beings?
Yeah, I've joked about that a lot. If the vegetarians found a very congenial environment
where they could eat all the vegetables they wanted, their intestine would get bigger and
bigger and their brain would get a smaller cortex and so on. The parts of this have all
been demonstrated. The more fibrous your diet is, the bigger your colon gets and you can
cause radical changes in a growing monkey, for example, just by the amount of fiber in
food. A poor diet very powerfully limits the growth of your brain. I don't know about the
distribution of body hair, but the length of the arms and legs is also something that's
very responsive to gestational conditions.
Georgie, I'm not trying to put you on the spot, but do you want to ask Ray that question
you talked about last time about the divergence of people that are following the rules versus
... Well, maybe I can just ask him. You'd probably do a better job. Do you know what
I'm talking about?
Which one? What do you mean by following the rules?
Like with the people that don't want ...
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah. Basically, I thought that evolution can work backwards too. Basically,
if the environment is not energetically conducive to maintaining higher complexity of species,
it's not just that apes are devolved humans. We may devolve into a lower level species.
My question is related to this lady's, is that, well, if the monkeys eat mostly leaves
and fruit, aren't the leaves very rich in the keto acids? Why would that be a poor diet?
I mean, it seems like they can get plenty of protein.
Because they're full of toxins. Lately, I've been talking more about the causes of human
development with a big brain and the areas where the biggest brains of fossils have been
found. I think if you look at the idea of evolving in reverse when you eat too many
leaves, instead of leaves, if you have a very good climate that produces huge amounts of
various fruits, the extreme concentration of calories, you can either get the necessary
proteins from the right selection of fruits, or you could occasionally add eggs and bugs
and so on. But an abundance of fruit would provide the high calorie guarantee that is
needed for maintaining the very expensive brain. The hunting diet, if you eat lots of
meat, which some evolutionists have suggested, the meat, even though it provides the essential
proteins, doesn't necessarily provide the very high concentration of glucose and the
materials for metabolizing glucose. It tends to cause hypoglycemia. In fact, the more meat
you eat, the more insulin you secrete to handle the disposition of the protein. And if you
aren't taking in carbohydrate, then the meat will give you chronically increased cortisol
and a tendency towards hypoglycemia from the maintained high insulin.
You're telling me Klaus Schwab wanting us all to eat bugs? He's on the right track?
What was that?
Klaus Schwab from the World Economic Forum. You know he's all about us eating bugs as
soon as possible.
Oh, yeah. They're, I suppose, adequate protein. Once I had some very nice things that seemed
to be like little fish patties, but after I'd eaten them, they turned out to be mosquito
larvae.
There's a Mexican restaurant in DC and they serve tacos made from locusts. Is this like
a common thing in Mexico or is this some kind of a monstrosity that they concocted here?
I never heard of the locusts, but around the lakes, you've seen the butterfly net fishermen
on Lake Patzcuaro probably. I don't know if they still do it, but they used to have these
big nets that they would skim the mosquito larvae with so they could collect them in
really nutritious quantities. And they had a pleasant, mildly fishy taste.
Oh, wow.
That has to be just pure punishment, like the bug agenda. The oligarchs are just like
mad and they want to abuse the citizens. And everybody eats bugs in Thailand. That's what
I remember. Okay, great stuff. Thanks for that, Ray. What does Dr. Peete, what Dr. Peete
thinks about life after death?
I never really think about it. I have read lots of discussion and more or less evidence
of it. A physics professor, one of the most famous physical chemists in the world, I always
have trouble remembering his last name, but he became notorious at the University of Texas
or Texas A&M maybe for doing experiments that showed transmutation of heavy metals into
gold. And after he retired, having experienced the powers that come to bear on anyone who
thinks outside of the system, such as believing that transmutation can happen at non-nuclear
energy levels, cold fusion, for example, he wrote about the history of communicating with
the dead. And his book, The New Paradigm, I think it's called, has lots of interesting
historical discussions of fairly convincing information transfer from post-living people
to presently living people.
I wish I had saved it. There was actually a great response to this question on the YouTube
comments section, but they started with St. Georgie's, "The living state is the degree
of electronic desaturation," if that's correct. And they were saying when you die, you go
down to a lower level of energy metabolism and a lower level of consciousness. Does that
sound right to you?
I think it's on a completely different level. The neutrino sea idea as the ether for interaction
of all substance, physical things like gravity and electricity, the common medium of neutrino
sea actually has pretty good evidence. And the neutrino sea can resonate for a very low
energy of the appropriate frequency, very low energy patterns can influence this ether
or neutrino sea. And I think that's where the telepathic and transgenerational communication,
how it's working.
So do you think what we call the soul may be something like a standing wave in the neutrino
sea?
Yeah, exactly.
Okay. For a layman, so the physical body disappears and we melt into this neutrino sea, something
like that?
Yeah. I'm not sure if it's still on the internet, but there was a very good video doing the
physical energy calculations called No More Secrets, a Canadian psychologist who died
first. That just shows the physical energy possibilities for these externalized patterns
that people can tune into.
So do you think that principle of deja vu that people experience, like they have seen
that before, it's basically resonating with a past, with the brain state of not even their
own, a basic of a previous life, so to speak, or a person that, I don't know, a very similar
energetically wise, if we can say that their soul may be still being in the neutrino sea.
So what we experience as ancestral memories could be just resonating with those standing
waves that are still there.
But the deja vu, where you are experiencing something that you can actually see it coming
at you, so you know, in some sense, you have already seen it. Our ordinary consciousness,
we are constantly foreseeing a little bit of the future, and we ordinarily only project
two or three or maybe four or five seconds into the future. But when you're listening
to someone sing a tune or make a sentence, you can anticipate what's coming, and there's
no simple dividing line between what's immediately past and what's immediately to come. The brain
is in ordinary things like talking and singing, the brain is very oriented towards forming
an image of what's about to come. And that can vary. Just a well-stimulated brain can
go much farther into hearing what's coming and interpreting what has just passed. If
you aren't attending to someone in a lecture, and suddenly at the end of a sentence, they
say a word that is important to you, you can wake up and replay, get back to the beginning
of that sentence, even though you weren't consciously recording it. So you can make
your brain back up and deliver something that you missed.
- I was just gonna say that the lack of clear dividing line between the immediate past and
the incoming immediate future, I think that line actually seems to extend way further
out, because there are studies published showing that people that have learned something as
little kids completely forgot it, and they went through some kind of a trauma, where
they basically, usually an electric shock of sorts, suddenly remember everything in
vivid detail from things that happened decades ago, and managed to basically reconstruct
through a story that was later verified, because I guess that event was recorded somewhere,
that they basically had an incredibly detailed memory that they were able to connect with.
It was way, very, very distant past. We're talking several decades.
- Yeah, and if you think of the incredible detail in that kind of memory that we're ordinarily
completely unconscious of, that kind of extreme detail, I think can extend into the future,
even though you're not attending to it. Sometimes the deja vu experience is when something slips
in your brain, and you forget to ignore enough of what's coming in, and suddenly you see
what's to come for maybe 10 or 15 seconds ahead.
- What do you think of synchronicity? Do you think it's a sign of us resonating well with
the environment? It seems to occur when people are in particularly good energetic state and
attentive to their environments.
- Yeah, there are a couple of very good books on synchronicity. One by F. David Peat is
a good one, pretty much the history of stories about it. But I think that's true that things
are, again, the ether or the neutrino sea, I think, is guiding causality enough that
sometimes things will choose to happen because you're ready to perceive them.
- I see. And one last question related to the, I guess, ancestral memories. There have
been several published cases of people undergoing brain surgery, and then when they wake up,
suddenly start speaking fluently a foreign language that they had never heard before
in their lives. What do you think could explain that? Would it be a resonance with, I guess,
with a dead soul or a previous brain state? Or what could it be? Because they've never
learned that language in their lifetime.
- One of the cases I read about many years ago was a woman who had been a cleaning lady
in some academic organization. She had spent years scrubbing floors and emptying waste
baskets for professors who spoke different languages. But just being present, when she
had a brain accident, suddenly she could speak the languages that she had been around, but
not knowingly attending to.
- I see. So the brain acquired, I mean, the brain is capable of resonating with past events,
though not always on demand. Something, some kind of a trigger is needed.
- Yeah. Aldous Huxley took up one of the ideas that was introduced, I think, at the end of
the 19th century and thought of the cortex of the brain as a filtering device. And when
something damages the cortex enough to get it out of the way, the full complexity of
reality can break through.
- I think I'm going to give myself a TBI to speak Spanish better.
- Are you familiar, Ray, with the Hinduistic ideas? Probably are, of prana and akasha.
Akasha, I guess, being the equivalent of the neutrino sea, where every event that ever
happened basically is recorded forever and continues to exist as an analogy, I guess,
of a standing wave. And then depending on the intellectual or consciousness state of
the person practicing yoga, they can tune into that and basically have access to all
of the events that have already happened.
- Yeah, that sort of thing, the new paradigm, has really been developing for thousands of
years in pretty much all of the cultures around the world. There's this idea that under certain
circumstances you can tune in and know much more than ordinary knowing could produce.
Like the George Wasson's story of the magic mushroom, eventually it turned out that he
was working with the government, but he was at the time just a hobbyist, a rich person
wanting to investigate the magic mushroom culture of Mexico. And one of their experiments
was to, because the people talked about the ceremonies as their mail service, just so
he could be there watching their procedures, he asked what was happening with his son in
New York. And the shaman told him that something very serious was going on. And so when he
got back to Mexico City, he called his son and found that he had got a draft notice that
day and was in an emotional state. But there are lots of stories like that where the mushroom
takers can focus in on something in very, very remote places.
- So the process of learning, would it be fair to say that it's basically the change
of the structure of that, or even the frequency of that standing wave in the Neutrino Sea
as we observe and interact with new events? Is that how we learn?
- I think so. Since very, very early, I don't really know when I concretized it, but I began
seeing consciousness as something electronic or finer, either the Neutrino Sea or a sort
of coherence of electrons, sort of like the conductive electrons in the metal. I've visualized
the process of consciousness in the brain as being this sort of a jelly-like ethereal
material that we push around with our biological activity in the nerves. But what's really
happening is that we are the resonance process in this conductive electronic or sub-electronic
substance. And so knowing, if that's what our everyday knowing is doing on its basis,
then those exceptional experiences of knowing things we shouldn't know would fit in with
the idea that we have adopted a way of using our cortex to filter out those ultra-fine
details of reality.
- Amazing stuff. Thanks for that, guys. Please ask Dr. Peet about the safety of dental implants.
Are there issues in terms of inflammation/autoimmune response or toxicity? Thank you.
- The stories I've read about the failures have made such an impression on me that all
of the successes don't seem very important when you hear about someone's jaw falling
off basically, the bone disappearing, the jawbone disintegrating to the point that they
have to put a metal jawbone in.
- I kind of forget about this, but I got my tooth knocked out a long time ago in 2009.
I have a plastic retainer. What kind of devastating things is that doing to my health, do you
think?
- Just a plastic over your tooth, I don't think it hurts anything especially.
- It's one that covers basically, it's like the front left tooth, so it covers all the
teeth on the top. It's kind of ruining a lot of the back teeth because it's constantly
there.
- Yeah, I don't think it does any deep harm, but the idea of putting a foreign object,
the teeth are separated from the bone by very special barriers, but to dig right into the
bone and put a foreign object inside the bone just doesn't make biological sense. Sometimes
the body can handle it and you won't lose your jawbone, but when it does, there's hardly
any repair that's satisfactory.
- So would you say dentures will be safer? Basically, they can do the exact same thing
without the implantation risks?
- Yeah, all kinds of restoration are preferable. Crowns can often be done on a basically destroyed
tooth.
- Amazing. This one's from our friend Dodie. She says, "We know the purpose of the vaccine,
if that's what you want to call it, but what is the purpose of the booster shot for COVID
and how does it relate to the variant?"
- The increasing insights into the appearance of the variant so-called, it increasingly
looks clear that the variants are nothing but the side effects of the various nucleic
acid treatments. The first reaction of people like Luc Montagnier was that the variants
were caused by the immunity to the first one and so the virus would mutate and become maybe
more and more infectious, but usually that kind of resistance of the host generally leads
to it becoming less deadly while being more infectious. But as the information has come
in, it looks like there might not be any such thing as a gamma, delta, whatever variant,
but simply that it's a name that's being given to the symptoms produced by the original vaccine.
And so if that's the case, then the booster shot is, if it's the real vaccine material,
it's just going to produce more so-called variants, more vaccine symptoms.
- Great stuff. Thanks, Dodie. Thanks, Ray. Okay. "Does Ray identify himself as a social
anarchist in the sense of excluding rent-seeking, forming worker cooperatives, freeing the individual
from authority, collectivism, direct democracy, mutual aid, et cetera?"
- No. I think organization, if it's allowed to develop, the systems have been very quick
to kill any incipient organization, but to the extent that they can spontaneously come
into existence, you'll have consumers, cooperatives, and producers, cooperatives, and the organization
will be what suits the people on the ground level. But if that's allowed to develop, it
will develop, and they will find the best way for these ground-level cooperative organizations
to cooperate on a larger and larger scale. So I think that's a natural course of development.
If they could, if some of these spontaneous cooperative groups could somehow take over
the state, then you'd have the problem of maybe the consumers having more control than
the producers. But if it grows up from the ground up, you're going to have to solve the
problems of each level of organization as they come about. So I don't think there's
any problem with evolving even a world-level state as long as it's based on these spontaneous
surface-level...
- Is there any truth to, I mean, the way it at least looks to me is that the social structure
and the political structure are in a sense a metabolite of the health of the people that
are building them. So if the people are relatively healthy, they can thrive under a variety of
systems without them being exploitative and degenerating into the worst that a particular
system has to offer. So instead of worrying about a specific political system, wouldn't
be the most prudent thing would be to just sort of like optimize or maximize individual
health and then see what kind of structure emerges from there?
- Yeah, because different cultures, for example, military-oriented cultures, there's evidence
that they are very tightly connected with child abuse and body mutilation and repression
of sexuality in children. Those things are closely tied with sadistic group policies
and sadistic war-making, head-chopping and so on. And you don't want one of those societies
to take over a larger government. It has to be basically an indulgent social organization
that doesn't oppress its own children.
- But in a group of healthy people, that sort of society wouldn't form to start with. My
concern is that as soon as we say, "Oh, we should prevent that sort of culture taking
over and then establishing itself," then the only way to fight such a vicious thing is
through basically other kinds of violence, which ultimately tends to be kind of self-defeating
because if you continue this conflict long enough, even the good peaceful culture will
eventually militarize itself through this constant conflict that is being going on.
So it seems to me that the only way to ensure a sort of like semi-stable existence of a
large group of people is make sure that as many of them are as healthy as possible and
then natural or non-exploitative order should arise.
- Yeah, the problem is that an urge to conquer tends to lead to conquest. And that involves
such things as being hostile, outline good food, for example. The conquest can take the
form of establishing a medical system that doesn't allow preventive methods, says everything
has to be focused on killing the pathogens, cutting out the defects and so on. So a society
that asserts the importance of being healthy is itself in danger of offending the sadistic
cultures and stimulating oppression from them.
- So I guess there is some truth to the saying that eternal vigilance is the price of freedom
even for healthy people?
- I think so. Until two or three generations, you might outgrow the sadistic tendencies
that have been inculcated for so long.
- 164 people watching right now. Thank you guys so much. Sincerely appreciate it. Give
this episode a like. All donations here will be sent to Ray. I don't think I sent you the
last donation. I've been very busy, but I will send them to you. I promise. Georgie
Dinkov, thank you so much for being here. Obviously, Ray, thank you so much for doing
this so regularly. Such a pleasure to have you on. Okay, this next question. What does
Ray think? What does he think is the role of estrogenic predominance in sexual orientation
and paraphylic disorders? So sexual fetishes, nymphomania, excessive masturbation, and porn
addiction. What do you think about that, Ray?
- One of the problems with high estrogen is that it doesn't allow sexual satisfaction.
It's the prod to seek satisfaction. It requires a good balance of thyroid and progesterone
and androgens to achieve satisfaction. And so it can lead to such things as nymphomania
or insatiability. And at the same time, it has this toxic excitatory effect on the brain.
So it can contribute to obsessiveness, hyperactivity, poor attention, everything you do to increase
your biological energy and vitality is tending to keep estrogen subdued.
- Amazing. So a similar track. Is celibacy dangerous in a relationship that will be long
term for the foreseeable future?
- I think it's always a result of an imposition, like these sadistic cultures suppress women's
sexuality in particular. And they start very early by often mutilations, including circumcising
both girls and boys to remove the satisfaction of sexual interest.
- Amazing. Thank you for that, Ray. Okay, last sex question here. Not to put him in
the public ire, but does Ray think homosexuality is optimal normalcy?
- If it's optimal or what?
- I don't really know what they meant by that, but I guess your take on homosexuality.
- I think the gist of the question is the person thinks that homosexuality is driven
by hormonal imbalances and it's not in an optimal healthy sexual state.
- Yeah, the evidence from history as well as animal experiments are that you can produce
it by stress during gestation. Everyone is abnormal in some way. It isn't something that
I think law should be involved in regulating in any way. But I think the evidence is clear
that it's a particular product of both prenatal and early life stresses.
- Have you seen the more recent studies demonstrating that finasteride can pretty reliably induce
homosexuality in animals?
- No, I haven't seen that.
- Well, I mean, I guess you can never know if an animal is homosexual or not, but they
started displaying the male animals started behaving like females and started courting
the other normal males and assumed like a mating position and basically started behaving
like females. And when they stopped administering the finasteride, basically they became asexual.
They stopped behaving like females, but they didn't revert back to behaving like males
either. And only when they were administered very high doses of testosterone did they sort
of not completely sort of revert back to acting like normal males sexually.
- How long ago was that done?
- That study is, well, it's not that old. I think it was from the late nineties.
- To tag along with what you said, if a culture is promoting stress in every way, shape or
form and then stress promotes homosexuality, it's not like a moral judgment person. They're
just expressing what the signals from the environment are telling them to do, right?
Thanks for that, Ray. Sincerely appreciate it. Okay. Let me, okay. I get this question
a lot. So this is why I'm asking. What are Ray's thoughts on Adolf Hitler and his expulsion
of banking cartels and masons from Nazi Germany? And then the other part of this question was
a little too hot for YouTube.
- He had many right perceptions, but in a very crooked way. He convinced the voters
that Germany had been close to revolution. And the fear was that the voters would gradually
support a Bolshevik type of government. And so all of the money and bank powers of Germany
and England and the US concentrated on supporting him as the barrier against Bolshevism. And
he developed a language that would convince the voters who wanted social welfare, guaranteed
employment, healthcare, and so on, good transportation and so on. He talked to them and said he would
give them socialism, but he told the bankers there would be national socialism that wouldn't
threaten to benefit anyone outside of German society. And so he had lots of progressive
pro-worker things for German citizens, but at the same time, he was following the instructions
of the money system. And his anti-Semitism was partly just to convince the working people
that he had an awareness of the manipulators of money and the banks. But he really was
working with some of the top Zionists, and they wanted pressure on European Jews so that
they would move to Israel and set up a new country. So there was collaboration between
the Zionists and Hitler for a while, but it finally turned into the murderous anti-Semitism.
But the things such as the anti-masonry, that was part of the German culture at the time.
He used those things to keep his mass support along with giving them cheap little cars and
high-speed highways, things that simply made the Germans able to be distracted from what
he was doing elsewhere.
Amazing. Thanks for that. Okay. How might Ray respond to the question of why worker
ants are sent out into dangerous conditions while queen ants are protected other than
worker ants are not reproductive, cannot pass on genes anymore? Well, queens can. Same with
bees. I wasn't joking when I said ants were observable national socialists. Their organism
also strategy is clearly designed around a collective effort to provide for reproduction
of the tribe's genetic material. And they have a rigid deterministic caste system where
sterile ants are sterile their whole lives and will readily give up their lives to protect
the productive queens.
But at the same time, individual ants can be intelligently altruistic one ant to another.
So it's a hierarchical structure, but they're also altruistic to each other at the same
case when they actually should be competitive if there's truly a national socialistic system,
right?
Yeah. And there are lots of good people doing good things in the United States, for example,
even though the system is definitely not designed to have good people doing good things.
Let me ask the question, which Danny didn't, but it's right there. Somebody asked, is Ray
Pete a communist? And I know it's a very loaded word.
I thought you answered it already. That's why I didn't answer it.
But no, there was another one where he's a social anarchist, but somebody asked directly,
is Ray Pete a communist? There you go.
I'm not sure what the difference is. If you define either of them very thoughtfully, there's
not really any difference. You want to get rid of tyranny and you want to have cooperation.
And the idea of communism essentially goes back to Christianity as the main source of
those ideas, and it has developed a lot of historical confusion around it. But the Christian
beliefs are at base, you could say that they're predominantly communistic.
Didn't William James say that Christ was a communist or something along those lines?
A lot of people have, because of his attitude towards money changers and the common person,
even the outcasts of the system, he was definitely a bottom-up person. And you can call that
anarchism or communism either way.
Do you think it's possible to have Christianity without the involvement of the church? And
by the church, I specifically mean corrupt structures like the Vatican with their history
of child abuse and financial machinations and supporting the Nazis and everything else.
Yeah, I think one of the most interesting books on Christianity was Wilhelm Reich's
book, The Murder of Christ. And he gets much of his guidance from the New Testament.
Amazing. Okay, let me search real fast for... I skipped this question. Okay. In regards
to an extremely morbidly obese person in their 40s and 50s, what are the first steps they
should do to tackle their weight? Would some fasting regimen like Alternative Day or OMAD
be feasible in this situation simply because of the danger posed by their weight? If they're
300 plus pounds and they simply might not live long enough to take the slower PUFA depleting
bioenergetic route?
And what were the alternatives?
Well, they were saying, should I fast or should I do one meal a day? Or I guess another possibility
with liposuction, like if somebody is extremely obese, what do you think? And they don't have
a lot of time. What do you think they should do?
All of the alternatives are extremely harmful. And I've wondered whether there might not
be a type of surgery to remove...
Glow?
Oh yeah, do we just lose Ray? Yeah, we do. Okay, I thought it froze. Okay, let's... Oh,
Ray, are you there?
Yeah.
I think we just... You just dropped out for a second. I think we can just start that question
over if you remember.
Okay. The amount of damage is something that can be investigated. The way liposuction is
usually done, just sort of stirring a suction tube around in the fat causes lots of nerve
damage as well as liberation of free fats into the system. And there might be surgical
ways of removing a large mass such as abdominal fat while doing less systemic damage. With
good local anesthesia, for example, I think it might be possible to unload 40 or 50 pounds
of fat without doing terrible damage. But a fast, especially if you're fat, that fat
is going to travel through your brain and liver and other organs on its way out of the
body. And so you're exposing yourself to a great prolonged toxicity. Even though I've
seen someone fast steadily for two months to get over extreme obesity, I'm not sure
your lifetime effect on your health is going to be worth it.
What about chemical interventions? I mean, there is a tremendous track record of things
like dinitrophenol being able to cure effectively even extremely morbidly obese people, of course,
under medical observation because it can easily kill you if you overheat. Wouldn't something
like that be considerable?
Overdosing on thyroid does the same thing. At the right level, it can increase your safe
oxidation of fats while helping to suppress the toxic or random oxidation. Both DNP and
thyroid can carefully controlled can reduce the toxicity of getting rid of the fat. But
I think diet high in calcium and vitamin D should be part of the program because they
will support safe oxidation and provide the nutrients that, for example, a high milk diet
will keep your metabolic rate higher and suppress the toxic effects.
Amazing. Thank you for that. Okay, about 10, 15 more minutes here and then we'll let you
go. Ray, thank you so much. Thank you, Georgie Dinkov. Appreciate it. Okay, let me find this
question. Aside from painting, does Mr. Peet recommend any other practice for positive
brain effects such as knitting, sculpting, etc.?
Whistling, singing, playing a French horn, playing a recorder whistle, playing the cello
or violin, all kinds of things that are very structured and stimulating.
Wouldn't things like gardening and tending to animals also work?
Oh, yeah.
Amazing. Okay, James says, as a social animal, humans seem to have a need to belong and experience
connection with other people. How can we meet this need in the current authoritarian anti-life
culture and avoid a life of atomized loneliness?
I don't know, but I keep looking around for what people can do. Just the simplest personal
contact if you can get three or four or more people together with a similar interest, such
as little music groups, something that is harmless looking to the society, but getting
people together, they're going to talk about their fate under the present system. So anything
you can think of to put people into personal contact, I think is going to eventually lead
to political progress and organization.
This person says, on the most recent Radio Network interview, Ray talked a little about
pheromones. He said a woman's emitted pheromones can change the way she is on birth control
and again when she stops. Does Ray know what a woman emits and what she responds to changes
in the lead up to menopause? And can a man's pheromones change as well, making him less
attractive to his partner?
Sorry, this is a really long one.
Can a woman's lack of interest in her long-term partner be due to pheromones? And last thing,
can anything be done to restore the pheromones to attractiveness again?
Good diet and hormone activity is the best thing to optimize the pheromones, but it's
true that both men and women have less of the attractive pheromones and probably gradually
increase some repellent pheromones. I think little kids emit anti-sexual pheromones that
I think they induce parental attitudes towards them. And then around puberty, the chemistry
changes towards sexual attraction. And to a great extent, I think the same attractants
are emitted by both men and women, but with some subtle variations that I don't think
anyone has a very clear idea of what a woman's attraction chemistry is. But I'm sure it can
contain some of the steroids that men emit.
Super simple question, but what is a pheromone? Like what, it's released by hair follicle?
It can be any chemical that is volatile enough that you can detect it at some distance from
the emitter. Fatty acids of different sorts work for insects and other animals, but the
most clearly defined human pheromones are derivatives of androgenic steroids.
Amazing. Let's do one last break here real fast for talk about Progest-E and then I'll
ask you one or two more questions. Let you go, Ray. Okay. So Progest-E from Keenogen
emailed Catherine to purchase a bottle. She ships very quickly. She packs it in this like
Mylar or something that protects it during shipping. It's keenogen@gmail.com. Each bottle
Progest-E contains 3,400 milligrams. I have a photo here. This is DHEA in this little
thing here. And then I have a little tiny $15 scale and then I mix it in this glass thing
I got from Japan, which I'll never go back to again.
A glass of Japan. Japan, unfortunately, because I will never
travel again, unfortunately. And then you can, the newsletter is available by email
now is $28, which can be paid through PayPal. And I mean, best deal on the internet for
Ray's bi-monthly newsletter. And you can also purchase his books. And those are basically
collector's items and I'd recommend everybody obtain them. Okay. So, so again, I think we've
talked about this many, many times, but I, I guess we can't talk about it enough. So
this person says, if forced to be inoculated, are there any supplements or diet that will
counteract the harmful side effects of the mRNA vaccine?
The first thing is to consider your defenses and resistances, how you can avoid getting
it put into you. And if you can find alternatives, such as a certificate of pre-existing immunity
or maybe a form of a vaccine that doesn't contain the nucleic acids, because the present
ignorance, the reason the experiment is being done is because it has never been studied
in humans before. And so you don't know what the outcome is. And as long as it's experimental
on its surface, meaning we don't know what the long range outcome is going to be. And
the animal evidence is that there could be terrible long range effects such as increased
susceptibility to all kinds of infectious diseases or to cancer or to brain degeneration
or sterility. So if you allow yourself to be vaccinated, you're taking a big experimental
gamble that the outcome of which you won't know as long as you're alive.
Are you disturbed?
The fact that the so-called variants are tremendously increased in the people who had the vaccine
suggests that the disease effects of the virus and vaccine are essentially identical and
that is primarily through the toxic effects of the spike protein. And that is a fundamental
and total promotion of inflammation in every system, hypertension, development of autoimmune
diseases. Everything you can think of is promoted, which is promoted by angiotensin
is going to be a possible outcome of a vaccine. So the angiotensin receptor blockers and antihistamines
and aspirin were known way back 10 or 15 years ago to protect against the toxic effects of
the spike protein. The toxicity of that protein has been studied now for a long time. And
so the Chinese were among the first to realize that angiotensin receptor blockers, antihistamines
and aspirin simply by being anti-inflammatory were the first things to resort to.
So does the mRNA that's in the vaccine, does it use the same mechanism through the
ACE2 enzyme to get inside of the cell?
Well, once you get the RNA in, it doesn't matter whether it's free RNA that comes into
you after being shed by someone who is vaccinated, it most likely is either in an exosome form
or as free RNA coming out of their breath and skin and saliva and getting into your
system.
So what I'm getting at is there is no way to prevent the mRNA present in the vaccine
from getting inside of the cell, similar to how we can prevent the virus from getting
inside of the cell, the wild virus, by giving something like Losartan or anything that blocks
that specific entry pathway.
Nothing I know of. They're using a lipid for getting the RNA quickly into the cells,
but other studies show that you don't really need the lipid. It will be taken up even in
the naked RNA form and that's just a tendency of cells is to take up circulating molecules
and sometimes they can be either assimilated or destroyed, but this particular fat happens
to take the highest concentration in the ovaries that distributes it in every kind of cell
in the body.
I'm moving a house in November and I found a place that I really liked and we were doing
all the paperwork and the owner was like, "Can you send me your vaccine papers?" And
I was like, "Yeah, there's no way that's going to happen." And they're like, "Oh yeah, you
can't move in there." I was like, "Oh, great."
In Mexico?
Yeah, a gringo owned the house. But it's just a sign of the future, I guess, or things
that come. There's a very interesting, entertaining situation.
Okay, Ray, were you going to say something, Ray?
No.
Okay. Ray Peete, thank you so much. Stay on the line for just one minute, Ray. Georgie
Dinkov, thank you so much. Is there any parting words, Ray? And Georgie Dinkov, any parting
words?
Well, I guess to me, the Appalachians start looking more and more attractive. If it's
extremely rural and poor and has no internet and no cell phone service, I think it should
be considered.
Guys, we have an amazing audience. Cecilia, appreciate it. I get so many positive messages
about these shows. They're so fun to do. Took a lot of work. Thank you so much, Ray, for
making these so special whenever you're on. Thank you so much, Georgie, my partner in
crime. And thank you for the amazing audience. Give this episode a like, subscribe to the
sub stack or follow the show in some way, shape, or form. And then also send all those
donations to Ray. Guys, thank you so much. Have an amazing weekend and we'll see you
sometime next month. Okay, bye everyone.